الوزير بلينكن بدا
متفائلا بخصوص امكانيه التوصل الى صفقه
رغم
التحفظات
الاسرائيليه برايك هل من مبرر لمثل هذا
التفاؤل نعم اعتقد ان هناك مبرر للتفاؤل
ان وفد حماس في القاهره يتحدث الان عن
امكانيه الوصول الى وقف اطلاق النار وهذا
يثبت ان الابواب لم تغلق بشكل كامل من قبل
كلا الطرفين رئيس مجلس الوزراء نتنياهو
قال انه
يرفض المعروض ولكنه اضاف بناء على ما
شاهدناه حتى الان اي انه يتوقع امورا
اضافيه وبالتالي هذا مشجع للاداره
الامريكيه بشكل كبير واعتقد ان الاداره
سوف تستمر في جهودها الدبلوماسيه وللعمل
مع الاطراف الثالثه وخصوصا دوله قطر ومصر
بالاضافه الى الحديث مع الاسرائيليين
للحفاظ على هذا الزخم ولو كان قليلا صحيح
سيد دان ان
نتنياهو لم يقل
بالحرف انه يرفض العرض ولكن ما عدده من
مثالب يعني ضمنيا انه لا يقبل ما
عرض
في الحقيقه النقطه الاساسيه التي يرفضها
الاسرائيليون هي وقف العمليه العسكريه حتى
هزيمه حماس بغض النظر عن ما يعنيه ذلك عدد
كبير من المراقبين يرون ان حماس لا يمكن
القضاء عليها لربما هذا الهدف لا يمكن ان
يحقق بالاضافه الى ذلك هو لا يود ان يوافق
على وقف مفتوح لاطلاق النار او وقف نهائي
لاطلاق النار برايه هذا ياتي بالفائده
لحماس هاتان النقطتان الشائك تان لان حماس
عبرت ايضا عن هذا الرد وهناك مجال للتفاوض
يتعين على المتفاوضين ان يحاولوا ان
يتوصلوا الى اتفاق يرضي الطرفين ولكن هناك
سبيل للمضي قدما ولو كان كانت المساحه
محدوده والجميع وخصوصا الولايات المتحده
والسيد بلينكن ولا شك سوف يعود الى
المنطقه وياتي بشيء جديد